right let's go ahead and get started
today we're have a presentation by one
of our clinical informatics fellows and
one of our clinical informatics
department faculty on sprinting towards
better clinician engagement and I think
they're going to talk about some work
that's going on in the clinical
Enterprise most of you know Brian Tran
who is I guess are you technically
second-year now or um technically okay
technically still a first-year clinical
informatics fellow but not not for long
because he started when was it last
April and Budd garrison who is a faculty
in the program and works in the clinical
informatics department in the hospital
he also is a graduate of our graduate
certificate program right did you know
you didn't do oh oh you did the the oh
oh that's right okay okay great
okay great great anyways and I don't
want to set a bad example but I actually
have a meeting in the dean's office at
11:30 so about like 11 22 or so I'm
gonna quietly exit much to my
disappointment but the dean's office has
to take precedence sometimes when they
schedule meetings so okay Brian
joining us today and again my name is
Bryan Shannon when the informatics
fellows today we're here to talk to you
about sprints and how we're using
Sprint's to address clinician engagement
again I'm here with but garrison he is
one of the directors of clinical
informatics and he's been tasked with
bringing Sprint's to OHSU specifically
to address clinician engagement so just
a quick outline of our talk today we're
gonna be talking about Sprint's first
we're gonna give you guys an
introduction to what Sprint's are
discuss clinician engagement how are you
using Sprint's at OHSU and then we're
gonna give you a couple examples of how
we've used brands to address certain
issues that we've come across in the
clinics first what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna play you a short YouTube video
just to bring us all up to speed on what
Sprint's actually are to our sprint
process the big idea with a sprint is to
build and test a prototype in just five
days it's kind of like fast-forwarding
into the future so you can see this
words here we go
i'm jake from GV and this is a
super-fast intro to our sprint process
the big idea with the sprint is to build
and test a prototype in just five days
it's kind of like fast-forwarding into
the future so you can see how customers
react before you get all the time and
expense of building a real product every
sprint starts with a big challenge a
team of about seven people and a clear
calendar on Monday you'll create a map
of the problem and choose one specific
target on Tuesday you'll create
solutions to your problem but instead of
a shout out loud group brainstorm you'll
work alone to sketch detailed competing
solutions on Wednesday you'll pick the
best solutions instead of endless debate
he'll use a structured decision making
process on Thursday you'll build one two
or even three realistic prototypes these
prototypes are just a facade of a
finished product you can use tools like
keynote marvel and envision to create
fake apps and websites or to quickly
prototype hardware you can use a 3d
printer or modify an existing product or
just prototype the marketing materials
finally on a Friday you'll test your
prototypes in five one-on-one customer
interviews you'll find obvious patterns
some solutions will work but some won't
either way you'll have clarity about
what to do next
and a great start on that big challenge
to learn more check out our book sprint
it's got detailed hour-by-hour
instructions and it's packed with
stories about startups like slack and
medium and flat iron health good luck
with your sprints and thanks for
watching so that's a general
introduction to sprint so sprints are
short time bound events where we have
very defined tasks and the goal is to
implement very short tests with change
and adapt very quickly to the feedback
that we receive from them so from this
graph we're saying we have an idea and
we're testing it and we're adapting on
the fly rather than spending a lot of
time building and implementing things
so Sprint's in healthcare Sprint's have
been used generally in the technology
field and we've seen them as a basis of
agile software development when it comes
to healthcare a place like the
University of Colorado has actually
implemented Sprint's and what they've
done is they've used two week time-bound
rapid process improvement events where
they're targeting very small but
meaningful issues in clinics and what
we've seen is they've actually been able
to make some pretty dramatic outcomes
with that so the model that the
University of Colorado has used they've
done two-week sprints they have a team
of 11 physician and nurse informatics is
epic analysts and also their CIO they
have that comes go into the clinics and
they've done rapid cycle workflow
improvements as well as targeted EHR
training and the important part of this
is their outcome measures are they've
reduced provider burnout improve access
improve charge capture and also improved
quality metrics so they've actually
pretty much addressed the quadruple aim
by implementing Sprint's and one of the
interesting and timely takeaways is by
targeting HR training and improving
workload they've been able to reduce
provider burnout a lot of the data
that's coming out about provider Burnet
is showing us that upwards of 30% to 50%
of providers are reporting burnout
across specialties some of the sub
specialties that are more burned-out are
primary care clinics as well as
neurology and neurology when asked
providers believe that things that
contribute to burnout are charting using
the HR as well as interactions with
members of the care team and what we've
seen is a lot of the studies that have
been trying to address these issues
teach an adult who's the chief wellness
officer at Stanford he's published
widely about provider Burnette and one
of his assertions is that clinician
engagement is the positive antithesis to
burnout clinician engagement is
characterized by vigor dedication and
observe
work wears burnout is the opposite where
it's exhaustion cynicism and reduced
effectiveness
they've also published organizational
strategies to reduce burn out and
promote physician engagement among these
are acknowledging and assessing the
problem developing and implementing
targeting targeted work interventions
and cultivating a community in at work
studies that OHSU have actually studied
clinician engagement and they've
distilled the recommendations down to
three things that should improve
clinician engagement here at OHSU three
things are improving clinician
satisfaction fostering communication
with clinicians as well as developing
clinician leadership development from
the framework that we've seen from the
call the University of Colorado the goal
is to use prints to provide targeted HR
training addressing clinic related
frustrations and at the same time
measuring burnout with the Maslow
burnout inventory with the targeted HR
training what we're trying to do is
identify gaps and increase proficiency
and the tools that we already have
available to us when it comes to
addressing clinical related frustrations
as we'll soon see
there's a lot of there's a lot of
crossover between what we've between the
contributors of burnout and when we're
addressing these clinic issues we're
looking at them in terms of people
processes and platforms when we're
providing targeted EHR training there's
some in epic called the epic provider
efficiency profiles and it has three
main components one is EHR proficiency
so this is how physicians use
customization and efficiency tools
there's also the provider efficiency
score which outputs a calculated
expected versus actual time in the EHR
based on provider workload and then you
can also drill down in terms of how the
providers use the system specifically
times
and after hours time spent in their
inbox what the turnaround message
turnaround time is and also percent of
same day chart closures and the goal is
to have a physician in fermat assist
review a clinics pep or provider
efficiency profile and the provide
targeted training during the sprint
process and some of our future
directions that we're hoping to
integrate into the target eh our
training is correlating the metrics from
the provider efficiency profiles with
burnout specifically answering the
question does lowering or does lower
proficiency correlate with increased
burnout and if we address HR training
can we also address provider burnout one
of the things that we're also working on
is using redcap to capture pre and post
results of the Maslin burnout inventory
after our interventions with the
targeted EHR training as well as
addressing the issues in the clinic the
next component of our sprints is to
address clinical related frustrations
and as part of the Sprint's a survey
goes that to the clinic staff and
providers where they basically provide
feedback in what issues they're
experiencing after
feedback is given the responses are
displayed in the clinic and the staff
are able to vote in prioritize which
issues they'd like to address we're
going to go through a few of the issues
and how we've addressed them one thing
to note is as I mentioned we're looking
at them in terms of their processes the
people in the platforms and a lot of
times when we're looking at burnout
you'll say oh it's the HR that's causing
us to burnout but one thing that we saw
when we address these issues is it's not
just the HR but it's the context that
these issues are arising and the context
in which they're using them so without
further ado we're gonna look at one of
the issues we dealt with in neurology
neurosurgery clinic sorry so one of the
issues were pituitary questionnaires are
too lengthy and redundant patients are
tired of filling out the same form every
visit and it takes up a lot of ma time
to enter everything
we looked at the actual forums and there
were paper forms there were five pages
long and one thing note is they used the
same form for every pituitary patient
what we did was I we scanned in the form
and I just took tagged what each section
was so they have the allergies the
medication lists past medical history
past surgical history social history a
general review system and then a
pituitary focused review systems and for
any of the clinicians here you could
tell that some of the stuff is from the
Agent P and this is things that may or
may not need to be addressed on every
single visit but this was a standardized
form that we used so when we talked to
providers what the providers told us was
that they didn't really rely on this
information because it was rarely
completed prior to the clinical
encounter and that they would ask his
questions anyways even if they didn't
have this form when we asked the amazed
about how they use this form they said
that the pituitary symptoms section of
this questionnaire was transcribed into
a flow sheet but because of the time
that it took the patients to fill these
questionnaires out they would usually do
it after the encounter and then the
entire five pages were scanned into the
patient's chart so just to summarize our
findings the questioner was redundant
many of the questions that were also
addressed at the MA in a general rooming
workflow such as reviewing their
medications the same questionnaire was
used for both new patients and
established patients once we have their
past medical password history generally
that doesn't change from visit to visit
the questionnaire was also rarely
completed prior to the clinical
encounter also the pituitary symptoms
only offered same better or worse and so
if a patient had new symptoms this was
either written has worse or not at all
so here's a swim lane diagram of what
the workflow is like so patient checks
in they received the questionnaire and
because of the length
it took them pretty much the entire
encounter to complete it
they would then give the
form to the ma the ma would enter the
answers into a flow sheet
they'd scan the paper copy and none of
this information was actually related to
the provider so our tests have changed
so first what we did was we created two
separate questionnaires one for new
patients which did include a lot of
their pertinent past medical history
past surgical history current
medications and then we also had an
established patient questionnaire which
was only the pituitary to eteri symptoms
which went from five sheets down to two
another thing we did was we added a new
field on the symptom questionnaire so
here's original where you see there's
checkboxes for same better and worse and
the new and improved form now has a
section for new so if they did develop a
symptom from the last visit the provider
could quickly look at that and address
that
another thing we implemented was
modified workflows I mean we encourage
the AMAs to transcribe the torture
questionnaire into the flow sheet as
part of the remaining tivity and with a
reduced length in the questionnaire that
was actually able to be done so this is
our new workflow with our tests of
change so patients to check in they
received their questionnaire because
there's only two pages long that they're
able to quickly submit it the MA takes
it they enter in the answers into the
flow sheet as part of the reading
process when the provider comes to the
room they actually have all the
information ready for them to review and
address so outcomes the pros were at is
we establish establish patients were
able to complete the form prior to the
moving process relevant literature
questionnaire symptoms were heated up
for the provider to review and it also
decreased the need for scanning
documents some of the cons that we came
across were the formatting the flow
sheets were not optimal for inputting
into progress notes and actually led to
some note bloat which is something that
we're going to address on our next
iteration and our next steps around this
is my chart questionnaire possibly
and with the idea of allowing patients
to complete questioners prior to their
appointment there's actually been a
debate in terms of the usefulness of my
chart of questionnaires and
questionnaires that are sent out at the
time of the appointment being placed may
actually be three or four months out and
just a temporal or the event may not
make it relevant for when the patient
actually presents also not all patients
have my chart so because of that we may
actually be supporting two workflows
rather than one another next step is to
optimize flow sheets for documentation
we're looking at different vehicles to
actually implement the the questionnaire
just to ensure that the note bloat is
not an issue and we're not contributing
it to you were seeit our habits any
questions about that no okay so the
second issue we addressed was from a
neurology clinic we had a number of
issues surrounding communication between
mas and providers the actual quota is
communication between MA and providers
about room and patient status clinic
flow of communication running around
whole clinic to find people so when we
did our workflow analysis we identified
the problem as such only there was only
three to four medical assistants for
about 15 to 17 providers forever for any
given clinic session providers also had
a very varied schedule that would change
week to week day to day so an example
one of the doctors would be there on the
first and third Wednesday and then again
on the first second and fourth Thursday
which made it difficult to anticipate
where they were and because of this the
AMAs actually changed the way they
assigned themselves they did their
assignments on a first-come first-served
basis for the patients and so they
weren't actually assigning themselves to
providers and why that was the problem
was there wasn't communication and
providers would not know who was rooming
their patient which we identified as
probably the route of the communication
breakdown another contributing factor
was providers had
for needs depending on their
subspecialty some of the providers who
had procedures would need it like a 10
to 20-minute ma commitment other
providers only needed two minutes from
their patients and so depending on which
clinic you were covering seeing rooming
a patient might take 20 minutes or might
take two minutes and the amazed knew
which providers were requiring which but
it very pretty much patient and patient
day today
so to summarize the issue was unclear ma
and provider assignments providers want
were unable to communicate with the ma
is because they did not know who's
rooming their patient so our test of
change was to assign providers to mas
per clinic walk aim and p.m. we had
assignments that were done on a daily
basis they're written on the wall in the
MA workspace as well as in the provider
workroom we also had the Amaze team up
into like a a squad and B squad so they
would always have coverage and there
would be assigned coverage so they knew
if they were stuck in room doing a
procedure that someone else would take
over for them and then one aspect that
they really liked where the teams were
able to cover for each other for lunch
before if things got busy they would
either skip lunch or take lunch at two
or three o'clock when things calmed down
but by having this this team there were
was an expectation of having coverage
the feedback we received was it did
improve communication ma is liked it
because there was a mechanism to cover
for each other some of the cons were the
daily ma to provide our assignment took
almost an hour to complete on a daily
basis and the reason being where the MAS
would do this manually they would open
the next day's chart and they're trying
to distribute patience to ensure
everyone had an equal distribution make
sure that everyone had a variety to
different exposures to different sub
specialties as well as the count for
add-on providers so sometimes a provider
may say oh I need to see a patient
tomorrow and then just show up and that
would kind of throw everything for a
loop each clinic had upwards of a
hundred patients so divided
was between three or four mas looking at
all these different variables was very
time-consuming what we ended up doing
was we looked at some data that fam and
I actually pulled up the department
appointment reports and from there we
were able to see when providers showed
up for a couple months back
based on that we were able to come up
with a estimated time of what the
schedules would look like so we
presented this to the maze and we said
you can do it manually or we can
actually have this estimated schedule
where everything would be predefined and
initially they were skeptical and what
they did was they would do the manual
schedule as their gold standard because
I knew that would keep things fair if
you will and they also looked at ours
and we found that our schedule based on
data got them about 80 90 % there and so
it actually improved their time by from
like an hour it's about 15 minutes so
our outcomes with where we were able to
reduce the time to create that main
provider assignments the cons were it
didn't really account for the add-on
providers and if there were add-on
providers that was something that would
have to be addressed at the daily huddle
and patient assignments weren't equal on
a daily basis but what we figured was if
you stretch it out over a week or a
month they should even now but if
someone was saying you know 15 patients
one day and your colleague listing 18 we
can't really account for that if we're
guesstimating things but one thing that
we've learned from this is this is a
good example of not letting perfection
be the enemy of good as it got us to 80
90 percent of the way there and it
didn't require so I'm spending an hour
sitting there manually like telling
patients up and as we mentioned the next
steps were using the daily Huddle's to
review the patient assignments add-on
providers and making adjustments from
there but at least they had a framework
to go off
so conclusions from our Sprint's is a
prote taking a social technical approach
is important a lot of the issues that we
looked at were not just about the HR a
lot of more about people processes and
the platforms and the context that these
issues Ludd we're in one other thing we
talked about was some of the clinic's
they had very similar issues but we took
different approaches for each one
because of the context in which those
issues lied and also provider engagement
is crucial and it as we're going about
this it's still a bit of an issue and I
mean but we're talking about this before
saying that we can't really improve
provider engagement if all we do is
address ma issues future directions as
you mentioned we're planning on
correlating the provider efficiency
profiles with burnout looking at what's
the impact of targeted training looking
at HR proficiency in the setting of
burnout and also using redcap to capture
that premium post intervention and then
the goal from here would be to bring
Sprint's to all Hsu clinics any
questions that's that's it
a lot of the impacts thinks that a lot
of the impacts were on the MAS and the
question of kind of the relationship
between the MAS burnout and turnover
with the clinician burnout with your
survey are you doing the burnout
inventory with both the clinicians and
the ma zouri yes everybody all the
clinic staff take the Maslow burnout
inventory but in terms of the provider
efficiency profiles those are only for
the providers but we're looking at
burnout for everybody across the board
right I guess what I mean is that even
if you don't see a drop in the burnout
inventory for the clinicians in the
short-term while the mas might have
better results are there other metrics
like turnover and things that eventually
over a longer trajectory would play into
how the clinicians feel about this even
if that short-term improvement doesn't
trigger the kind of score drops you're
looking for so comment on that we've
done we're now just wrapping up our
fourth sprint so to give a little
history we did two of these last year as
a pilot project in that pilot project we
initially just sent the mouths Lac to
the providers right and kind of
realizing and dipping into a little bit
of your questions we decided well number
one that needs to go to all users and
then of course you know not thinking
that through Holi right about our third
one we said a way we ought to maybe need
to identify in that survey are you an MA
or an RN or whatever so it's been a
little bit of an evolving survey we do
now have a role based in there where the
person can pick their role and we're
tweaking that role a little bit
depending upon the practice that we're
looking at our next clinic is going to
be the comprehensive pain center they
have a lot of alternative therapies
going on they have chiropractors and
acupuncturist and massage therapists and
several other things involved in that
clinic so we wanted to break them out
but then also you kind of have to look
at that if you're going to keep the
survey truly anonymous about how you
label those roles so if you say well are
you a chiropractor and you only have to
in the department it kind of figured out
right who's answering we did also allow
in that survey recently that people
could identify themselves if they wish
to so and then also in that survey in
the pre survey is a way for them to
bring up those daily frustrations in
their workday that we want us to tackle
and that's the other comment that I
wanted to throw in is this is funded
under the clinical engagement a3 which
is an institutional program to focus on
provider and clinical user burnout what
we've seen in a I think Brian mentioned
this out of the studies multiple studies
going on around the country is the way
that we reduce that burnout is long-term
we address frustration in your clinical
work day communication amongst your
clinical team and Trust and leadership
that we're giving them tools to do
anything about number one and number two
right initially we do surveys on on
what's your frustration your clinical
day and they say epic sucks right that's
what you hear right long-term when you
really look at the data what you find is
it isn't necessarily all tied to the EHR
so in these four Sprint's that we've
done we've had roughly around 200 issues
brought up from frontline clinicians and
staff and clinicians and faculty I been
meaning to do the numbers on this but I
think if I go through that issue I think
in just looking at it quickly
my guess is less than four percent of
those are directly related to the EHR
now we have a lot of EHR impact with
those operational things that we try but
both of the issues that were brought up
here
they had impact on the EHR they weren't
primarily EHR issues
same thing that's being borne out in
multiple studies university colorado
university of kansas several others
about burnout in how we impact that per
net so what becomes really really
important in this process and what we
try and reiterate when i go to set these
Sprint's up with the practice manager
and the medical director in the chairs
and then go to faculty meetings is to
say what we want to bring forward is
what are the frontline faculty and the
staff frustration in the clinical day
right what is that pebble in the bottom
of your shoe that's just annoying but
not annoying enough to quit hiking and
take the pebble out so we're here to
take the pebble out of the shoe so tell
us what the pebbles are and we do a
multi-modal approach to collect those
frustrations in the users words and
that's really critical i believe is that
we raise those up in their words and we
a group we may group them together in
themes but we still address them and
report back to them in their words what
they brought up as being an issue what
they as a group prioritized for us to
work on and then what they as a group
came to the table to develop solutions
to fix right because if we do anything
other than that if we take all of those
and we state them all in our words and
combine them into themes that we think
are important and then hand them back to
them it's nothing more than hi I'm but
I'm from the government I'm here to help
right and it it doesn't truly
specifically discreetly address their
frustrations in their debt so I just
wanted to throw those little comments
and I'm happy to answer any other
questions
about staff feeling empowered or maybe
accountability for how the operations
actually go it sounds like you're
stepping in and filling a gap there
because people aren't apparently finding
ways to address their frustrations on
their own so you're addressing that gap
and so exciting to hear about the work
that you're doing
how will you empower these groups to
continue this after you leave are you
adjusting like the the accountability or
roles in the clinic so that it has like
a long term effect and they kind of take
this as a springboard to go oh hey let's
keep doing this in all areas of the
clinic I think part of what we're trying
to do is actually give them the mindset
that they can do this and for every
issue that we've actually addressed
we've asked them how do you think that
we should fix this what do you think
it's gonna work rather than I mean the
issues that we brought forward we didn't
say hey you should do this we said hey
well how do you think we should improve
this and yes we may have had suggestions
but we're modifying everything based on
their feedback we're not saying you have
to do this and I think like the MA stuff
they came up with a lot of that
themselves as well and as they kind of
gave feedback and said hey this is not
working this we should do this we did
actually move towards that and every day
we just kind of touch base with them how
do you think this is working what else
do you think we could do and but as the
Sprint master if there are barriers then
they'll try to knock down those barriers
if there's something like hey maybe we
should try both Sarah's or we need
technology you will go get those right
but I think one thing that but always
tells them is the whole point of this is
to show them that they can do this and
they don't really need us to do that
right it's like Dumbo with the little
feather right you've always had it now
you can do it we just have to show you
that you can yes
yeah that's really not the stated but
certainly the underlying goal right is
our goal with this whole program is to
instill that mindset that they should
incorporate this into their daily work
it is really interesting though and it's
been interesting for me over the last
six months kind of starting up and in
getting into this process because you
know we've had the lean culture around
here at OHSU for quite a while and that
takes on a different path in every
organization it the the lean it's a lean
process improvement so here we call that
OPEX or the OHSU performance excellent
system I think is what it's called I've
been to way too much training on that so
I should probably have that ingrained in
my memory but so that is lean
methodology the lean process improvement
coming out of Japan and what 60s I guess
in 70s a continual process improvement
is really what it is and how do we go to
the frontline of the work and we make
sure that our users on the frontline
have an ingrained that part of your job
is continually improving the process of
how you do your job which can be really
tough in a clinic that has 17 providers
only three mas on that day and a hundred
and ten patients to see right so how do
you get that engrained and that is
definitely one of our goals is is to get
that and now back to I'm sorry I don't
mean back yeah back to your comment or
your thought about long-term cultural
change and long-term change in the
burnout what we've seen in the
literature is that this sprint us going
in and doing one two week sprint in the
clinic it helps about that much right
but we don't see cultural change in
reduction in burnout until we're through
a second or a third phase of this that's
what kind of what came out of University
of Colorado but it is that long term
mind
that changed because that increases the
more that they can see everybody can see
that we're focused on this issue and
that we're bringing tools to truly help
the more you increase the communication
amongst the team the more you increase
the trust that leadership understands
the problem in is putting tools in the
hands of the users to reduce that to
improve their work and reduce their
burnout and that's where we see the
change so this isn't a silver bullet
there is no silver bullet to anything
right and but it is it is a way to
long-term effect change so you guys have
a limited engagement time with the the
clinic that you go to I know that you
have an extended planning process and
then there's a there's a there's a post
engagement process also but but to me it
seems that the real wild card here is
the variability of practice that you
will see in individual clinicians when
you actually go to the clinic and and
and since these kind of variations in
practice of especially physicians can be
pretty significant how do you kind of
plan for that so that you know you
actually have time to address individual
concerns as opposed to trying to make
workflows processes better for teams so
what we're doing our team that we bring
in consists of at the moment myself as
sprint master right so I'm running the
process and then we have a clinical
workflow analyst out of our epic
informatics specialist team we have a
performance or a process improvement
consultant I keep calling them
performance improvement consultants then
they correct me that they're there to
fix a process not make people perform
better which i think is important so so
we have a pic from our ambulatory
team from funded under the OPP so there
they are very plugged into the overall
standard work that's developed to
standardize operational work across mas
across schedulers so when we go to look
for a solution what we're doing is first
of all we want to refer back to the
standard work that's being developed to
standardize operations across the
university so if they say hey we have a
problem we're not using the dots and
EPIK to communicate patient status or
provider status consistently across the
clinic and that's come up in three out
of the four clinics we say okay let's go
to the standard work that's being
developed and here is the standard that
you should be using now anytime you put
standard work in and this is a very much
a lien or a continual process
improvement methodology right you
developed your job breakdown and your
standard work of how you want the work
done you always need to put the process
together to inform that standard work of
when you need exceptions so we bring the
standard work forward we say the first
thing we're going to try as a solution
to that problem is we should try the
standard of how we want to use dots
across the enterprise now if we come up
with a reason why that won't work in
this specialty and in this clinic then
we'll make sure we have the people there
to make sure that we inform that
standard work and either do an exception
to standard work or inform and change
the standard work so it's more broadly
useful so that kind of one example about
how we're trying to not over customize
the operational processes now when we
get into the actual clinical process and
clinical practice of the provider
we try not to touch that in this process
so once you get the provider into that
exam room with it except for some of the
exceptions like the pituitary
questionnaires is a very good example of
that when that was raised up as an issue
this is why we love having our
informatics fellows involved because now
I have an MD that can go sit down and
talk to an MD about the
clinical use of these questionnaires and
what value is it now I'm not an MD I've
been around this environment since I was
like that high but however I don't have
the credibility of that or Brian or
anybody going and sitting down from a
clinical perspective and addressing that
so that's why we have an MD on the team
and why we need to that's one of our
early lessons learned as we need to have
an MD and clinicians on that team to be
able to affect that change but one of
our stated goals of this that I talked
to the practice managers and the medical
directors and the chairs when we go to
set up a sprint is the one thing we want
a respect and not touch unless you tell
us to is that provider to patient
interaction that provided a patient time
did that kind of inter probably more
than you wanted and I want to make sure
we get your question in because you kept
trying to raise here I mean I don't know
big of a question it is
is something that you want to see
something where there not only do they
do the providers gain the sort of agency
and they gain the sort of empowerment
that is so important for preventing
against burnout but but in some cases
they may not start out with the tools
that kind of Informatics Esprit in with
being able to program for example and
create those estimated schedules is that
are those skills that you kind of expect
teams or clinics or hospitals to start
building like long term or do you expect
them to keep needing to bring you in or
bring in some sort of infer masses from
the outside or some outside consultant
in order to get those tools made once
they identify their needs
yeah and that that's an interesting
problem about how much do you resource
individual clinics for that build work
is that kind of that and boy that's us
that's a struggle right because the
problem is the more that I take a build
analyst especially to build within the
EHR the more I put that build analyst
siloed in a clinic the more
customization I end up with it's not
necessarily long-term supportable or
that meets standard work that we're
trying to bring to the table across the
organization does that make sense so
there's a little bit of almost a
slippery slope that if I go too far down
empowering clinics to do their own
building do we do we go over that
customization too far so one of the
things outside of this process that
we're in the process of implementing is
a wider use of physician builders across
the institution so physician builders as
a program put out my epic where I can
have identified physician informatics as
their clinical informatics Asst where we
send them back to epic for training a
lot of our fellows have already gone
through that program that they go back
to epic they get a training in the
in how to build certain user-facing
tools within epoch and so we're we've
changed our physician informatics
support model to be a much broader
specialty so we're funding more
providers for less amount of time than
we have historically so that they can go
get that training and then they can
represent their specialty knowledge and
help build those tools but also be
plugged into a governance structure that
makes sure we aren't stepping too far
down that customization road that makes
sense
because you know you get too far down
that customization road and your
enterprise reporting just blows up right
if you have internal med family med
cardiology all reporting differently on
metrics about how they manage cardiology
patients good luck reporting on it right
it's just gonna be back on that I think
you know as I'm a physician in training
and I think I don't know if you if the
room agrees with this or if you agree
with this but I think that another you
had the list of three things that
contribute to provider burnout and one
that I think was sort of art it was
brought up but maybe not explicitly
stated was this idea of like mastery and
learning and having that be something
that is I'm communication is there but I
think that's a little bit more broad
than this idea that like without that
like concept of mastery and building and
learning that that kind of feeling like
empowerment to but really like getting
getting better at something I think that
that's sort of another one thing that
you might consider in framing burnout
but then Brian this is very interesting
my question is how much do you think you
can take from one clinic and quickly
disseminate it and another clinic
because I know there's so many clinics
that you guys are targeting and for
example this ma scheduling issue would
you expect that you can use the time
that you spent at the neurosurgery
clinic you can use the outcome that you
had clinics so there's another example
we didn't really touch on but there's
something that we've seen or I've seen
in the last two clinics and it's
properly prepared patients so
neurosurgery they had an issue where
patients would show up without all the
imaging so what we actually did for them
was we built out almost a checklist
within the chart and based on their
diagnosis the PAS would be able to go in
there and track where they were with
that patient so if they did have an MRI
where was an MRI because is it within an
epic institution and can be pushed or is
it outside and they need to actually
request it and so that framework that we
were able to implement they've actually
used it and we've standardized how the
chart scrubbing occurs for the PAS in
order to reduce patients showing up
without proper imaging or lab results
and in Neurology we've also seen that
come up again and I think certain tools
like that can be generalized to other
clinics as well agree with that and I
think that's the benefit of having a
team kind of longer term and making sure
that we're informing standard work my
interesting thought around that though
is you know one of the purposes of this
is to make sure that we're honoring what
the user brings forward as an issue and
honoring their buy-in to the solution
right so wouldn't now a lot of times
when at least in the four that we've
done so far and in my work and other
programs you know you do get clinics
that'll say yeah we've got this problem
somebody else must have saw
that and then we can say oh yeah we saw
this over a neurosurgeon this is what we
tried maybe it'll work here maybe it
won't right but we have to make sure
that we get there by into giving that
solution a try and I know that's kind of
a fine point rather than saying oh yeah
boy you screwed that up here's your fix
because then we don't necessarily have
their buy-in to the fix and yet we've
become again
hi I'm bud I'm here from the government
to help right we come imposing solutions
on them which is shown not to truly
affect burnout it's actually shown to
increase the frustration in the clinical
day because they're not bought into the
overall solution if it fails they have
no Buy in to making it better they say
wow this is another thing bud threw at
us and it didn't work right should
probably fire bud
is the idea then to have kind of
clinician and format assists physicians
that really kind of also know how to
build their own tools in epic kind of
embedded in every group or in every
clinic so that they so that they
themselves can identify the issues and
then become part of the solution by
actually helping to build that solution
we would absolutely love that we haven't
been able to get it funded because every
chair or every department administrator
we go to and say and we we we tried this
a few years ago say you should identify
a point person you need to identify a
point clinician that's gonna collect up
all the issues in your department and
you should send them to this training
and they say that's gonna take them out
of clinical work who knows how much I've
amount of time right then estimated four
hours a month to half their time a month
depending upon the size of the service
line and what level they're going to be
working on and so are you gonna pay my
department for that and we have been
successful here recently in going from
about one and a half FTE of funding for
physician informatics up to about four
FTE of funding spread over multiple
different specialties so funding three
people half their time to funding seven
or eight people one day a week right so
that's our strategy now we haven't been
able to go into you know 25 to 30
different service lines and get
commitment to have an identified person
that's funded in every service sign what
we have done is gone from having one
hospitalist half time with us when
pediatric hospitalist half time and one
ambulatory provider half time ambulatory
specialty provider I should say to now
having a point person one day a week for
primary care one surgeon one he monk one
pediatric inpatient pediatric pick
you pediatric ambulatory all point oh
one day a week funded that makes sense
so we're starting to broaden that out
what I hope to have happen is we broaden
that out we show the outcomes we
refocused them a little bit on this
personalization and the one-on-one
provider training about helping those
other providers that are struggling we
refocus them in that and helping them
build tools to support that and we show
the outcomes of the program and we
increase the funding that's what's
happened in other organizations about
the timing question though I think you
scared me a little bit when you were
showing the tech sprint videos because
it was like having a clear calendar for
five days and trying to imagine that
happening here even though I knew just
seemed staggering when you talk to a
clinic about wanting to do a sprint with
them what time commitment are you asking
them to make available to work with your
team and have you seen some variability
and how much time it can take versus we
know if you don't have X amount of time
that you're willing to make available
it's probably you're probably not going
to be able to do a sprint with this
group that makes sense the question yes
what we asked for might help if I go
kind of how we initiate with a clinic on
a sprint that make sense so what we
asked for in the video that Brian showed
was was fantastic to get the concept of
sprint so rapid cycle test of change
right we want to go in find a problem
figure out what we're gonna try to do
today about that problem come back
tomorrow talk about what we did today
and what we're going to try or what we
did yesterday what we're going to try
today so that model that was in that
video was much more of a system
development application development
mindset we're a lot more operational
than that so it's actually a much
shorter a much more varied timeline of
what we do during our two-week sprint
during that two-week sprint what we
asked for
is a 15 to 30 minute huddle we schedule
them at 30 minutes and hope to get done
quicker you don't usually make that but
we hope to get done quicker we asked for
15 to 30 minutes during either right
before or during the clinic day and then
we asked for to make sure that when
we're going to identify an issue and
we're gonna spend a little bit of time
in the clinic that day and that time is
going to be very variable right to
figure out what are we going to do today
so usually when we start a clinic on
Monday of the two weeks we go in and we
take that first huddle and we identify
issues a lot of times that first day is
let's go quantify the issue one of the
interesting things we ran across in
neurology was patient delays one of the
highest voted things on their list was
our we always have patient delays yeah
and so we're like okay let's root cause
doubt right let's figure out what it is
so we put some more abnormality tracking
around it for the first day or two and
we say when we know how we have patient
delays let's go check a box and say this
was physician running late patient
running late patient not prepared
whatever those categories are come back
the next day look at that and say well
do we have a root cause that would cause
us to do some kind of tests of change
and then Tuesday we say let's say we
have a you know providers running late
so how are we going to go address that
and then we just we just start picking
away at that right and maybe we address
it by making sure that the MA or pas is
keeping an eye on that when the provider
is running late a little tap on the door
say you've got five minutes different
clinics have approached out in many many
different ways
none of them are usually appreciated by
providers right but but we we give that
a try right come to the conclusion and
give it a try so that may take during
your clinic day 15 or 20 minutes out of
the clinicians time it may be a little
bit more time we do prop
them to say this is gonna be extra work
during these two weeks right you're
going to be busy we've had clinics ask
for extra staffing and their ma and pas
from the pool to get more people to help
that's been semi responsive right the
pool has been semi responsive to that
but we do set that expectation that
during this two weeks time you're going
to have a little bit more impact and we
need that engagement prior to that what
we do and how we engage with a clinic
I'd I have been going in meeting with
the practice manager I initially started
out meeting with the medical director
and we determined that row that really
wasn't successful go meet with the
practice manager and get the practice
manager to set you up with the medical
director in the clinical chair so we
meet with the medical director or the
practice manager medical director and
the chair depending upon how engaged the
chair is we talked about the Sprint
concept we get their buy-in thirty days
ahead of the sprint we schedule time in
a faculty meeting we come to a faculty
meeting and do a presentation we go to a
staff meeting and do a presentation at
both of those meetings we introduced the
concept of the sprint and as soon in
that conversation as we can introduce
that concept of we're here to chisel
away at those little pebbles in your
shoe of those daily clinic frustrations
out on the table I've thrown out a bunch
of sticky notes and pens and I say as we
talk about this the rest of the time as
you think about those frustrations write
them down on a piece of paper right hand
them to me or stick them up on the wall
on your way out the door and that's
another mode that we use to to collect
up those issues so we do a faculty
meeting we do a staff meeting the week
before we start a sprint we schedule
another hopefully combined faculty and
staff meeting where we take all those
frustrations we put them up on posters
of the wall we give everybody five dots
and we do passion dot voting so we say
now come through and vote on which one
is more important to you as clinics and
the one that gets the most votes that's
what we start with on the next Monday
when we
spirit so that honors them bringing
forward the issue then prioritizing the
issue and then them being at the table
to address the issue we're here to
facilitate and potentially plug you into
standard work in evolving standards in
the organization you know potentially
have clinician on a clinician time to
sit down and talk about the efficacy of
your questionnaires all of that right
but we're there to facilitate now for
follow-up we do what we're seeing in
most of the literature tells us that
it's 30-day we should wait 30 days after
an event to do another mass lack burnout
so at that three to four weeks timeframe
we send out the post survey that post
survey as another mass lack burnout
inventory and it's a way to collect up
their pluses and Delta's you know of the
whole process and get impact in input
into the process we'll take that data I
go back to a faculty and staff meeting
and present the data
[Applause]
questions or anything feel free to shoot
me an email